we're going to get some numbers for this
okay when you circle the ball every four
seconds we'll get a number
and then when we increase the angular
and the linear velocity right
most of you the vast majority of you not
everyone
but for this vast majority including me
when i first thought about this question
which is bad because i designed the
question um is i thought
i thought tension would increase right
now there's some intuition to that right
because we've looked at these kinds of
situations before right it's going at
this nice gentle speed
and i know you're not doing it with me
but you can imagine it's not tugging on
my
hand the tension in the string is not
very high now as i increase the speed
it starts to pull more and i have to
hold on to it how to almost just going
to fly off
right so tension in the string as i
increase the speed
it's also increasing okay so let's have
a look and see what happens
to the maths right the very first thing
i'm going to do and most of you executed
this just fine
is i'm going to take all of my constants
and i'm going to throw them into here
okay so we'll do vertically first
okay so what do we got here
t cosplay on 6 which is
round two right
um plus n cos pi on four
you know enough about me to know i
really like the conversation you're
having
just i mean not everyone got to the same
point where you were
is that okay yeah all right it's okay
where were we cos alpha what's called
alpha
cos pi and four it's one over two right
okay equals now we know what the mass is
and gravity
that's i should say times 9.8 okay
so far so good let's tidy this up a
little bit okay this is going to be
what's that 19.6 19.6
but i sort of want to clean this up a
little bit right so i'm going to
multiply through
by two as well okay so what i'm going to
get here is
that'll be root three t multiply this by
two you get
root two
okay so this is going to be four times
that which is oh i don't know
19.6 plus 19.6 which is 30
uh 8.2 no 9.2
9.2 of course it's not predictive okay
there you go there's equation one which
i get from vertical
forces okay horizontally
okay i'm going to go here and i'm going
to do exactly the same thing i'll just
save us a bit of time when you multiply
it out you should get
t plus this same factor because it's
signed alpha still one and root two and
you're going to get
i think four [ __ ] squared
yeah was that all right okay now in this
particular case
right i need to work out what omega is
right
um four seconds that's how long
that's how long it takes to go how far
one revolution which is two pi
radians right and i put it in this order
because
omega is radians per second okay so in
part a omega will be pi on two
radians per second all good
okay so when you throw that in uh you
square it you'll get you pi
squared on four four times pi squared on
four
pi squared yep
okay see okay so then what did we do at
this point
what are we trying to do
we're trying to solve the tension right
so you look at these two equations
right you see that well this number is
bigger than this
so i think you would do one minus two
yes
save you a bit of time eventually you
solve for t and i think to one decimal
place
you get 40.1 newtons so far so good
okay now when you go to part b a lot of
this is the same but what changes at
what line do i have to adjust things
line one line two line three line
four this line doesn't work anymore does
it
because it goes with this which goes
with this right
but that's changed okay so instead of
omega being pi on two
when you crunch this in i think you get
two pi on three
radians per second okay so you're going
to get something different on this right
hand side
when you do the same thing and you go
ahead and solve
right the tension in the string is what
is it it's like 20 something
29.6 29.6
it's less the tension in the string
is less how can the tension in the
string
be less right it seems to be pulling
on me more the faster i make it spin
but of course in this picture there's
something missing isn't there
what's missing from this picture what's
missing is there's no ball
because well frankly i don't have a bowl
that's you know that's just
this big okay but what difference does
the ball make
right the ball is pushing
its reaction force is pushing in this
direction okay
now as this thing gets faster right you
can you can now think of this
as think about how i said oh okay you
know so it's pulling on my hand more
right it's pulling further away further
away if i let go it'll really fly
right but if there's a ball there the
ball's pushing
back right and because it's pushing more
in that direction because it's going
faster
the ball is also pushing back more right
so therefore the tension in the string
drops
because the reaction force increases
does that make sense it's a bit
counter-intuitive right
but most of us when we anticipated that
it would increase not decrease
is because we forgot that there's a ball
there and it contributes its own
force and that force changes based on
you know
you push on a table the harder you push
on it the harder it pushes back
unless of course you know you're really
strong and it crumbles but i'm not that
strong
okay so i picked out this example
for two reasons because the hemisphere
is tricky because the angle of the
normal
changes as opposed to the cone it's
always the same it's always the same
okay so you need more information to
solve it
but secondly it gives you this really
cool counter-intuitive result
so i hope you learned something as you
got to this number and
brain exploded okay